the fda has approved the first new
alzheimer's drug in nearly 20 years
that's despite an independent advisory
board voting overwhelmingly
against it over concerns about a lack of
evidence supporting its effectiveness
adulhelm was tested in people with mild
alzheimer's
and is administered intravenously every
four weeks
the drug is intended to slow disease
progression it is not
a cure in a statement the alzheimer's
association called the approval
a quote victory for people living with
alzheimer's
and their families cbs news senior
medical correspondent dr tara narula
joins us tara good morning
this is a very controversial drug how
effective
actually is it do we know based on these
trials
well anthony that's really the million
dollar question you know this drug
is very different from the drugs that
currently exist this drug goes after the
fundamental underlying disease process
it's a monoclonal antibody given as you
mentioned as an infusion
that really targets those hallmark
amyloid plaques in the brain of
individuals
with alzheimer's disease with the hopes
of clearing or removing
those plaque lesions now the big
question is
does that translate into effectiveness
and so that's why there is so much
controversy here you have people on both
sides of the equation really
looking at the data and the two trials
that were analyzed by the fda
one showed that there was no clinical
effectiveness with this drug
the other one showed a minimal
improvement so
you have supporters really saying even a
minimal improvement is valuable for this
very debilitating
and devastating disease and critics
really saying
the effectiveness the evidence is so
murky and is the fda really lowering the
bar
here but what the fda's done is really
interesting they approve this
through a different sort of pathway an
accelerated approval pathway one that we
sometimes see with cancer drugs where
they said look
we don't have to prove effectiveness we
just have to show that there's a
decrease
in these amyloid plaques with a
reasonable likelihood that that will
translate into
effectiveness down the road very
interesting so tara what
what exactly does the drug do when you
talk about a reduction in plaque
what could that mean for an alzheimer's
patient
well if we surmise that this really is
effective you can imagine that the six
million
americans living with alzheimer's now
which is expected to by the way
double by 2050 that this will really
have an impact for many millions of
those suffering with the disease
and according to many advocacy groups
like the alzheimer's association
the hope is that this really will buy
individuals more time
time with family time for quality of
life
and that even minimal improvements days
or weeks
where you're slowing that cognitive
decline that's really valuable for these
individuals
and so this drug was tested in those
with mild
to moderate cognitive impairment not
really in those with severe disease but
it's been approved for
all of those with alzheimer's disease
and the other hope anthony is that it
will spur on
investment and research for other drugs
like this
well it's been reported though tara that
it's already controversial what are the
side effects
well there are always side effects and
that's why you have to weigh the risks
and the benefits and so
in these studies there were two main
things one was what we call
hypersensitivity reactions almost like
allergic reactions
the other more kind of relevant was a
little bit
or often seen brain swelling or
microhemorrhages or microbleeds in the
brain
many times these were asymptomatic but
in some cases they did cause
confusion nausea vomiting dizziness
falls change in mental status
and in fact 40 of the individuals in one
of the trials on the high dose
had this brain edema or swelling so that
is why for this drug
it is recommended that serial mris of
the brain be performed
during the course of treatment to
monitor for these events
all right dr tara narula thank you so
much for being with us this morning tara
thank you